boy the Jets were tough I don't know how  we did it but yo if you got there  someone selfie doesn't become an uh  sweet video hey how are you backups  doing just replacing a generational  talent you were undefeated  yes aim what there's another to be taken  care of at the end today we're all still  Tom Brady  he has everything I have a great  deviance [ __ ] kick a puppy  his own crunk come on I don't get a  Grunk to week 14 wrong hey man your  you've met this old guy before I want to  say it's Joe Montana you're an  inspiration  it's all coaching right oh I don't eat  coach always be pick one this is some  quarterback and that's okay you don't  see McVeigh shrieking himself into  Goff's brain if we're all made of  Stardust aren't we all iliyan so fast  hey you yeah I'll freakin hundred  thousand to you flippin listen to me  I'll be out about the anything lurkers  watching RBS so subscribe this cheney  channel or GT the fluff Oh daddy says  subscribe